despite everything that's been going on
the past couple of weeks despite
everything president Trump's approval
rating has gone up to 45% yes up to 45%
yeah ladies and gentlemen at this rate
he has two porn stars away from being
reelected this the best thing apparently
that goes over really well yeah yeah
yeah porn star I didn't know that
fantastic
yeah you know I got to get in on that
this morning a big story Facebook
announced major changes to its privacy
settings yeah yeah apparently they're
gonna start having some cry scientists
have invented sensors that you can mount
onto your teeth to track your diet from
inside your mouth yeah or you could just
eat less it's another way to go that's a
possibility this is a weird story a man
in the UK has a case of what scientists
are calling the world's worst super
gonorrhea
super gonorrhea yeah but because of his
British accent women still want to sleep
with him what are you hiding why do they
call it super gonorrhea it comes with
fries and large fries
I didn't just have an image in my head
now I don't we have anyone from Ireland
here it's exciting news Ireland will be
opening its first nude beach this April
and in May Island will be closing its
first nude B it's accepted worldwide no
one wants to look at a naked Irish guy I
don't know why my wife's a believer
you